nan
meji
me
バッハ
今日は同好会あのー
年配者女性の唯一の代表としてここに登壇させていただきますメガ幸子と申します
よろしくお願い申し上げます
私の慶應女子高等学校
約四半世紀前に卒業いたしました
でもさっき女子高生見たら制服が変わっていないのであんなつかしーなーという思いだ
日
常にしていますそしてあの
よく10校にクラブ活動で通ってたんですけど入った瞬間の臭いも全く25年前と
変わってなくて
がもし傘受講の文化なのかなというふうに感じた次第です
ではこんなところで一つ前ですよね山王ご覧になったことある方いらっしゃいますか
ほぼいらっしゃらないですね
いや自主的に見たことのある方いらっしゃいますか
ん
1名です人間ありがとうございます一気に減りますねでは映画のピクされが飲茶いる
ヘッドっていうの男頭で聞いたことがあると
また見たことあるって方いらっしゃいますか
基地にいますねっ
実はのあのフレームの古典ゲーム伝統芸能と言われているんですけれども
あの人の感情をテーマにした演劇です
in サールヘッドという家でも確か人の脳内をあのテーマにした映画だと思います
それを実は日本の農というのは650年以上前からずーっと続けています
主役になるは例えば葵の上でゲームがあります
葵の上という演目なんですけれども
その舞台に青色位は出てきません
実はですね
葵の上という名目
公有地ものをしたの舞台通りに置くだけで
この下のが葵の上役所になります
そして
そこの主役は何かというと名前をほとんど出てこない
六条御息所という
女性の嫉妬
または楽しみこれが主役になっている
そういうもの no です脳のテーマキッド哀楽この4つにすみません
出てくる出演者の生い立ちとか
歴史というのはあくまでも
この感情がどういうものだったかを示すためだけの思うんです
そして
そのあなたにもう一つ感情タイムの表現性の中にいつもの装束
そして表という6皆さんオメンって言いますよ
ここで覚えて帰ってください表と言います
そして
表は被るものではなく書けるといいます
これは
術をかけるという意味があるんですね要は
乗り移ってもらう表をかけることでその薬がぬ流ツール
そしてその人の感情を表現する
少し信じ的な要素があるこれが日本文化の能楽です
でもこのの
まぁみん未来芸術鑑賞会ぐらいしか見たことのない方がほとんどだと思います
学校の授業にも
入っていないですよね
それはもう今ですとあの25年前ですとうちの家と関税の問題梅若と関税の問題で完売
問題という ghq の母んだ
あの能の問題があったんですけれども
教科書になってましたが今はそれも入ってませんどんどん日本軍歌をそのさっきた知識
という感じがありますが日本文化の知識を得る場所が消えていってます
学びの場に今日本語変化はありませんほとんどありません
その結果私たちに通って日本文化というのはとても遠いものによってしてしまってい
ます
そのそれがいま何をどのようなことが漏れているのか
今日はこの装束を通してしていただきたいと思います
大変申し訳ございませんが半谷の代わりになっていただけました
手を広げてください
はいございます
本来はきちんとしてたよ後ろ向いていただきっ
こんな着方品等しないですでも見ていただくと分かりこの詩集
全部消し集
そして金箔これも出て全部貼っているものです
どんな感じですか
重い
できている企業はどうですか
ちょっと小洒落ですふぅ
じゃあこれが2000万の着物だと聞いたらどんなキープになりますが
うん
積んでいきたいです渡せませんが
はこれ3年かけて作られたものです
そして枚で2千万円以上の価値のある相続です
別に2000万だからすごい園て話したて2000万負けないとも作れなくなって
しまっているという現実があるんです
なぜならて仕事もいうのはとても時間がかかるものですし
1人針ひと針縫っていくてもすごく大変なことです
それだけじゃないんです
今その道具が日本でどんどん消えていってしまっているんですね
この詩集一つこれをぬ張り
て針の張りなんですけれども
て針を作る人は今日本で広島にひとりしかいませんこのて by を作る人がいなく
なってしまったら
て針を作るという文化がなくなりますじゃあ機械で作った針でいいじゃないという方も
いらっしゃると思うんですけど
作った方の塗ってる方に聞いたら
塗って失敗した時に糸貫ますよね抜いた時にパナ箱がすごくすごく残る
これが機械割だそうです手貼りだとなぜか絹の移動おい
傷めないで修正が効くんだそうです
だから私たちは彼女たちはてバリウムがなくなってしまったら今以上にいいものが作れ
なくなってしまいます
とよくおっしゃってます
そしてもうひとつこのこれは機械織りの絹の
ものなんですが
昔はこれもておりで元の着物作られていました
昔の人にも言っていましたねなんでかというと
機械で織ってるからテンション強さがあってどんどんどんどん目を詰めていくので
思うとなってしまうんですねで昔の仕立てで追っているから空気を入れて柔らかくて
良い場所は柔らかいまま
強くおらなきゃいけない強度の子必要な部分は強いままという形で追っていたので今の
この装束に昔の装束の方が軽いんです
この分担も非常に難しくて今
て畑の森もの中にあるひとつの部品
この部品は陶器でできているんですけれども
もうこれをつくっている人はいませんですから
いい風合い風合いで着物こういうものを例文だというのがだんだんだんだん消えてなく
なっていってしまうと思います
そしてもう一つ日本人独特の感性裏地です
金浦字コの裏地というのはこの表の
今日あのいろんな速人散髪にリスペクトしているのでこの裏地によってこの表上痛め
ないようにできているんですね
ですからどんどんどんどん裏がほつれてきたら今度はこれを張り替えて
使っていきますじゃした1回すごく高いを数減があったとしても
今回は200年300年と続く2区だけのクオリティを持った
着物になるわけです
今そういうものはほとんどできません
あとでどこかでゆっくり見ていただければいいと思うんですけれども支所に押し方一つ
何本当によくできてますまたこれノートような男性メーンの
具体なので
南西て来ついてじゃないからだ女僕は見えないと思うんですよ
ですからこれ本かきちんと着せると女性らしい体のライン
作れるように
昔は売られていました
一つの着物を見ても日本の文化というのがどんどんどんどん
あのどんなに素晴らしいものかというのがわかっていただけると思うんですけれども
第二世界体制が終わった後にさっきも申し上げたように教育の中に日本の文化考え方と
いうのも全く入らなくなってしまったので
皆さんのにとって日本文化というのは本当に外国の文化よりも程遠いものになって
しまいました
でも2020年オリンピックだというた時に安倍総理は日本の文化をもっと皆さんし
ましょうねっていうようなことを発言されてますよね
で美しいポンってもおっしゃってました
でもどうでしょう実際は
実際に今私たちの世代んでさえ
どうやって日本文化が成り立ってるのがご存知な方はほとんどいません
そのなかで日本軍と守れと言われてもはっきり言って困るっていうのが現状だと思い
ます
ただ本当に日本の文化とで今とても危機に瀕していて針1本先ほどいたてばリーポンが
なくなったら
こういういい装束は作れなくなってくるし
この装束というものがなかったら演じではもしかしたらどれだけいいものを待っていて
も
相乗効果の美しいもの見せられなくなってしまうかもしれない
お世話もし傘300年後のことかもしれないけれども
今足元がどんどんどんどん崩れていっているこの現状を皆さん知ってください
そして私は機会を否定するわけじゃないので
是非とも買い方達が何かも
時にほぉやったら手刺繍て仕事
そういうものをどういう風にして残していけるんじゃないかというのは相手だがあるん
だったら
今はその若い力をどうぞ私達に
でだして押してください
そうじゃないと皆さんが生きている日本の中で
はっきり言ってしまえば絶滅危惧種のようにん
日本の文化も生態系というのはどんどんどんどん崩れていってしまいます
と聞いていただいて
ね2000万ちゃんとして是非とも観ハトマンになるには
それってどうしたらいいのかなって君が入っていただけるといいと思うんですね
時間と効率ってすごく難しい問題なんですよ
昔のあの音の巣のは
パトロンでした自分がどれだけお金もつで盗んだといいものを知っていてどれだけ
素晴らしいの間
アピールするためにノート分の中で見せてたんだと思います
my dear のファッションショーに触れたコルデみたいなものだったと思います
だからこそ
いい物を作れなくなってもいいのじゃないーんじゃないのっていう思いは捨てていた
場合てっ
せっかくあのおじいちゃんおばあちゃんたちが持っていた精神とか考えたたっていうの
を見直すのもバルーンちゃん不安とないんじゃないってもらっていう風に考えて頂け
たら私はとても嬉しいです
40今4歳なんですけれどもになっていっ
実はあのやっと脳の仕事をに目覚めました
a
排出大学出たての時は電通と以降国大体に入って
報告について学んで
ちょっと脳っていうのは
まあ私からは縁遠いんじゃないかなと思った時期もあります
また男のこうじゃないので
あと次にもなるわけじゃないし関係ないわと思った時期もあります
でも私だからできることさっき申し上げましたけれども
人間国宝の娘には男の子だったらなれません
男の子だったら跡継ぎなので間違うぐらいはあるです
ですが今女性として生まれたことによって
あの乳とにゴンチと話すことができて
分館をつないでいく大切さを知って
そして今何を残さなければいけないかということを考えたときに
皆さんにこういうものを知っていただいてお話いただくうっちゃんそう
こうやっていただけたことはとても嬉しいことだと思っています
なかなか観るチャンスもないと思うのであとでゆっくり見てみてください
とてもいろんな刺繍の
縫い方になっています
さすがに疲れましたよねう
もすぐ興味があったらあとで機体がたおっしゃってみてください
なっ風
こうやって見ていただいても光の具合デー
多分金の色が変わっていくと思います待った時よはまあを取ったって言いますね待った
時に美しく見えるように光の加減ですき妻が変わるようにこういう色彩感覚とも日本人
にとって
とても大切なものだと思っています
ぜひこういう気持ちを忘れずにまたこういうような機体をどんどん増やして興味の
無かった事興味のある
なかった知識を学べる期待をこれからもどんどん増やしていってください
どうもありがとうございました